tenemos dos mangueras que podemos usar
para llenar de agua a un estanque usando
ambas mangueras nos tardamos 12 minutos
en llenar el estanque una de las
mangueras es más ancha que la otra y
para llenar el estanque usando solo esa
manguera se tarda 10 minutos menos que
si usamos sólo la otra manguera cuánto
tiempo se tardaría cada manguera en
llenar el estanque si usamos sólo una
manguera ok entonces tenemos nuestro
estanque y tenemos una manguera por aquí
y otra manguera por aquí y si usamos las
dos mangueras para llenar el estanque
nos estamos tardando 12 minutos pero lo
que queremos saber es cuánto tiempo se
tarda cada una de estas mangueras en
llenar el estanque si dejamos de usar la
otra manguera que ya sabemos que además
una de estas mangueras es más rápida que
la otra y se tarda 10 minutos menos en
llenar el estanque ok tenemos la manera
rápida
y digamos que se tarda no sé efe
minutos
2 en llenar una vez él es tan que se
tarda efe minutos cada vez que llena el
estanque y también tenemos la manguera
lenta y esta manera lenta se tarda 10
minutos más en llenar el estanque
entonces y la rápida se tarda efe
minutos en llenar el estanque entonces
la lenta se tiene que tardar
efe más 10 minutos minutos en llenar el
estanque
ok entonces podemos pensar que estas son
razones proporciones de cuántos minutos
se tarda cada manguera por cada estanque
que llenan pero si lo que queremos es
poder sumar estas dos cantidades estaría
mucho mejor tener la proporción del
estanque que llena cada una de las
mangueras cada minuto ok para obtener
eso lo único que tenemos que hacer es
pensar que tenemos
efe entre 1 porque en realidad si
tenemos eso tenemos que se tarda efe
minutos por cada un estanque que llena y
ya que lo tenemos de esta forma podemos
tomar el recíproco que es 1 / efe y de
este lado lo que nos queda son estanques
por minuto y entonces lo que nos queda
es que fracción del estanque se llena
cada minuto entonces esto es lo mismo
que decir que llenamos 1
/ efe
partes del estanque del estanque cada
minuto
minuto entonces bueno de hecho lo
podemos pensar como que llena un
estanque cada efe minutos o que llena
una pésima parte del estanque por cada
minuto que pasa y podemos aplicar
exactamente lo mismo con la manguera
lenta tenemos que la manguera lenta
llena 1 / efe más y es partes del
estanque estanque por cada minuto cada
minuto que pasa bueno voy a borrar este
estanque para tener más espacio
y entonces ya tenemos las velocidades
con las que las mangueras llenan el
estanque ahora algo que nos gustaría
también tener es la velocidad con la que
las dos mangueras llenan el estanque si
están trabajando juntas y eso pues es
simplemente la suma de estas velocidades
o sea si una manguera llena una décima
parte de un estanque en un minuto y la
otra manguera llena uno
/ efe 10 parte del estanque en un minuto
cuando ponemos a las dos mangueras a
llenar el estanque pues van a llenar 1 /
efe más 1 / efe más 10 partes del
estanque no entonces van a llenar esta
parte de él
y por cada minuto
bueno pero porque queríamos sacar esta
velocidad pues porque nosotros tenemos
por aquí que usando ambas mangueras nos
tardamos 12 minutos en llenar el
estanque ok tenemos aquí que usando
ambas mangueras nos tardamos 12 minutos
ok
12 minutos esto lo que nos dice es que
juntas las dos mangueras la rápida y la
lenta se tardan 12 minutos minutos cada
vez que llenan el estanque
qué tardan dos minutos por cada vez que
llenar el estanque pero nos conviene
sacar la velocidad con la que se llena
el estanque entonces tomamos el inverso
y nos queda en que para llenar una vez
el estanque
en que se tarda 12 minutos 12 minutos y
eso es lo mismo a decir que llena una
doceava parte del estanque por minuto lo
cual tiene todo el sentido del mundo no
sé si se tarda 12 minutos en llenar el
estanque pues en un minuto seguro llenar
una doceava parte del estanque ok
entonces esta es la velocidad con la que
las dos mangueras trabajando juntas
llenan el estanque pero eso es lo mismo
que teníamos por aquí así es que estas
dos cantidades tienen que ser iguales
esta cosa de aquí que la sacamos con
esta información tiene que ser igual a
12 sea bo
que por minuto
minuto ambas expresiones representan la
velocidad con la que las dos mangueras
llenan el estanque entonces tienen que
ser iguales y por lo tanto ya tenemos
una ecuación con una sola incógnita que
es la incógnita f
ok tenemos 1 / efe + 1 / efe más 10
igual a 1 entre 12 y si resolvemos esta
ecuación y encontramos cuánto tiene que
valer f
habremos encontrado con qué velocidad la
manguera rápida llenar el estanque y
entonces ya nada más tenemos que sumarle
10 minutos para encontrar con qué
velocidad la manguera lenta llenar el
estanque así es que pues vamos a
resolver esta ecuación entonces vamos a
movernos para arriba para tener espacio
para hacer las cuentas
aquí para encontrar a efe queremos
sacarlo primero del denominador así es
que vamos a multiplicar a ambos lados de
la ecuación por efe por s más 10
por efe por efe más
ok entonces este término por efe por efe
10 la f se cancela con la f y nos queda
simplemente este más 10 y luego este
término efe por efe mas 10 por 1
/ efe 10 entonces efe más 10 se cancela
con este más 10 y nos queda simplemente
una f y eso es igual a 1 entre 12 por
efe por efe mas 10 pero sabes que de una
vez por todas vamos a deshacernos de
este 1 entre 12 para que no haya
fracciones entonces vamos a multiplicar
por 12 de los dos lados de la ecuación
12 por efe mas 10 más 12 por efe y eso
es igual a el 12 se cancela con el 12 y
nos queda efe por efe mas 10
por este mes 10 y ahora si aplicamos la
propiedad distributiva lo que nos queda
es 12 por efe 12 por efe más 12 por 10
que es 120 más 12 por efe y eso es igual
a efe por efe que es ese cuadrado más
efe por 10 que es 10 efe ok entonces ya
tenemos una ecuación cuadrática porque
tenemos aquí f al cuadrado pero en puros
términos de f y algunos otros números
entonces aquí ya sabemos exactamente
cómo encontrar efe y para llegar a la f
lo primero que tenemos que hacer es
poner todos los términos de un solo lado
para que nos quede una expresión
cuadrática igual a 10 así es que vamos a
restar de los dos lados todo lo que se
encuentre por aquí bay menos 12
menos 120 menos otros 12 efe pero bueno
este menos 12 efe y este menos 12 efe si
lo sumamos nos quedan menos 24 efe así
es que vamos a poner lo menos 24 efe
y entonces tenemos que restar lo mismo
de este otro lado no creo estar menos 24
efe - 120 quedado cf más 12 efe - 24 efe
eso es un 0 y luego 120 menos 120
sincero y eso es igual
efe cuadrada 10 efe - 24 efe eso es
menos 14
y finalmente menos 120 menos 120 y ahora
ya que lo tenemos así de esta forma lo
que vamos a hacer es factorizar
estamos buscando dos números que cuando
los multiplicamos nos da menos 120 y
cuando lo sumamos nos da menos 14 y ya
sé exactamente qué número son son menos
20 y 6 que tenemos que esto es igual
efe menos 20 por efe más 6 porque menos
20 por 6 es menos 120 y menos 20 6 es
menos 14 ok entonces esta expresión
cuadrática es la multiplicación de estas
dos y esta multiplicación es igual a
cero si y sólo si alguno de estos dos es
igual a cero entonces nosotros sabemos
qué
efe - 20 es igual a 0
efe 16 es igual a 0 ok pero tiene que
suceder alguna de estas dos cosas para
que su multiplicación sea igual a cero
ahora en esta ecuación podemos sumar 20
de los dos lados del igual y lo que nos
queda es que f tiene que ser igual a 20
y de este lado restamos 6 de los dos
lados y nos queda efe tiene que ser
igual a menos 6 ok entonces si uno / efe
más 1 / efe más 10 es igual a 12 o efe
es igual a 20 o efe es igual a menos 6
pero en este momento recordemos que
significa efe efe es cuántos minutos se
tarda la manguera rápida en llenar todo
el estanque entonces no tiene sentido
pensar que f puede ser igual a menos 6 o
sea una manguera no se puede tardar
menos seis minutos en llenar un estanque
no entonces las fuerzas
efe tiene que ser igual a 20
ok efe es igual a 20 entonces ya
encontramos cuántos minutos se tarda la
manera rápida en llenar el estanque y ya
nada más nos falta encontrar cuántos
minutos se tarda la manguera lenta pero
la manguera lenta se tarda efe más 10
minutos así es que en la manguera lenta
se tarda 20 10 o sea 30 minutos
minutos
entonces la manguera rápida se tarda 20
minutos en llenar el estanque ella
solita y la manguera lenta se tarda 30
minutos en llenar todo el estanque ella
solita